Speaker 1: Okay. Let's do a little bit more
coverage of yesterday's second day of the January
6th committee hearings. Another major and obvious
scam that we all knew about except, of course,
for the millions of Trumpists who donated to it,
is that this so-called Trump official election
defense fund, which was going to fund recounts
and lawsuits and artists and all these different
things, it was a scam. It was a grift. It was
if you look at the fine print, obviously another
attempt for Trump to enrich himself by raising
money and then enrich his friends and family
by hiring friends and family and paying them out
of those donated funds. Well, it's another thing
we suspected which the January six committee
has now apparently confirmed to be true.
We have a video from yesterday's hearing where
Congresswoman Zoe Lofgren explains that the Trump
official election defense fund didn't actually
exist. It was yet another Trump grift and again,
a grift which victimizes his supporters.
Progressives were not donating to Trump's election
defense fund. It is a grift of his own supporters.
Speaker 3: I'm senior investigative counsel at
the House Select Committee to investigate the
January six attack on the United States Capitol.
Between Election Day and January 6th. The Trump
campaign sent millions of fundraising emails to
Trump supporters, sometimes as many as 25 a day.
The emails claimed the, quote, left wing mob
was undermining the election, implored supporters
to, quote, step up to protect the integrity of the
election and encourage them to, quote, fight back.
But as the select committee has demonstrated,
the Trump campaign knew these claims of voter
fraud were false. Yet they continued to barrage
small dollar donors in emails, encouraging them to
donate to something called the Official Election
Defense Fund. The select committee discovered
no such fund existed. I don't believe there is
actually a fund called the Election Defense Fund.
Speaker 2: The first election effects fund was
another. I think we can call that a
marketing tactic. Yes. And tell us
about these funds as marketing tactics. Just
the topic matter where money could potentially
go be our money could potentially be used.
Speaker 3: The claims that the election was
stolen were so successful, President Trump and
his allies raised $250 million, $250 million.
Speaker 1: Remember when I brought
the story of the grift to you?
Only about 70 million had been raised. And then,
okay, we figured out it's another grift. I wasn't
going to keep updating you about the amount of
money. By the time it was all said and done, $250
million had been raised, and it's a grift all the
way down. As an example of how the grift was even
further used for enriching Trump's friends and
family. Kimberly GUILFOYLE The then girlfriend,
maybe now fiancee or wife, I don't know of Don
Jr. She spoke for two and a half minutes at the
rally on January 6th. She was reportedly paid
60 grand for that speech, and that is the money
that came from the so-called Election Defense
Fund, which it's sort of like if I were to say,
if I were to say, hey, please donate to the
Democracy Defense Fund at The David Pakman Show.
If if you're just making a donation to The David
Pakman Show, just because I call it something
doesn't mean it exists, and it doesn't mean it's
being used for that. Like, it just gets mixed in
with the money that comes in from memberships and
whatever else. Just because you put on an email
official election defense fund doesn't mean it's
a real thing. And this was so obvious that it was
going on that the sad part is it's news to people
and many of the small donors who got grifter and
scammed are never going to know it. Now, is it
a crime? That's a great question. Congresswoman
Zoe Lofgren was asked, is that a crime? And
she said it's for someone else to decide.
Speaker 3: We're a legislative committee and.
Speaker 4: It's clear that
he intentionally misled.
Speaker 3: His donors asking to donate to the fund
that didn't exist and used the money raised for
something other than what he said. Now it's for
someone else to decide whether that's criminal.
That's not the purview of a legislative committee.
Speaker 1: Yes. And Merrick Garland, attorney
general, said they are certainly watching the
hearings at the Justice Department, but who
knows what the outcome will be? Another scam,
another grift. Not a surprise to
viewers and listeners of this show